looking at clayton kershawn his career
in this ballpark this season
he's got a one three five and three
starts here
and it is careers second all-time in
wins and in the ra at dodger stadium
throwing the breaking ball the slider
more often than he has in his whole
career
i guess you could call him a breaking
ball pitcher but really
you find out the difference between good
outings and bad onions with clayton
on how the fastball goes because when he
locates it and gets it near the edges
keeps it out of the middle of the plate
he's done very very well this year has
done a nice job this year avoiding the
home run ball too so the leadoff man is
on and jesus aguilar comes to the plate
we'll do the 3-2 pitch again with rojas
off of first
and aguilar out to center field backing
up
in front of the track because taylor
makes the play rojas back to first one
down
1-2 to cooper got him swinging would
have been the best slider that he's
thrown yet on a first inning full of
good ones
a few of him had to have that cutting
action and some have had some really
good depth like that one
and adam duvall stands in 1-2 delivery
curveball got him looking strike three
he froze him with the hook
and duvall goes down looking second
strikeout for kershaw
sandy alcantara gets the ball for the
marlins tonight his ninth start of 2021
and no decision
against milwaukee on mother's day brings
a 272
era into tonight's ball game
two earned runs or less in six of his
eight starts
this year left-handed swinging corey
seeger
runner goes throw to second not in time
another stolen base
for mookie betts
ground ball right side nissan diaz
bobbles has enough time to make the play
up to third goes mookie betts and there
is one away
sandy going to the change up to get it
done 2-2
to turner and he chases one upstairs at
99 miles an hour
tipped into wallock's glove first
strikeout for sandy
and there are two away that's what sandy
has it's an overpowering fastball even
the game's best hitters have struggled
to catch up at 99 miles an hour at the
top of the strike zone
kershaw hit the lead off man then went
one two three getting a couple k's in
that first inning
five six and seven coming up here got
him with the slider
that's the pitch that he added and
launched him to cooperstown this one's
slightly up it's got
good movement good morning good
afternoon good night wally
clayton kershaw looking strikeouts on a
one two three second
luck still just 23. he played this
entire season at 23 years old
slices a drive to left center field that
takes off and gets
[Applause]
they've got a teed up here for pollock
second and third nobody out
one two sharply hit and it makes its way
through
aj pilot drives home chris taylor and
the dodgers strike first
it pierces the shift first and third
still nobody out the hitter is barnes
drills the ball way back to left
it is off the top of the one
barnes into second with an rbi double
that close to a home run
no home runs on the year but this is
about as close as you can come to making
it
your first aj pollock had to go first to
third on this play and immediately
training staff came out and he's having
to show them that he's good to go
and i don't think they're convinced alex
is going to have to leave the game
kershaw up with runners at second and
third still nobody out
right-hander set now the pitch and this
one pumped up the middle of base hit
baity will score barnes held at third
and clayton kershaw
with his second rbi of the season on a
one-two pitch
he poked it right into center field
three-nothing dodgers
five in a row have reached open this
inning the bottom
five in the order and a chance for a big
big
frame already three in the bank is 2-2
down the line pass the diving anderson
into the left-field corner
barnes can walk home kershaw stops at
third on the third double of the inning
the ball gets by but kershaw's not going
anywhere it's four
nothing and there's still nobody out
doctors have three balls
above a hundred miles per hour off of
the bat in this inning alone
seeger pulls it off
[Applause]
2-1 delivery swung on and well hit to
center field
this ball back this book got a three run
shot maxwell swinging the silver hammer
again three straight games muncie has
gone yard
dodgers had three more it is eight
nothing
cooper struck out in the first one oh
pitch to him
is looped out toward right center gonna
get down for a base hit the marlins are
on the board sierra scores rojas digging
for third
he's in there standing without a throw
so garrett cooper delivers
and it's 8-1 now on the top of the third
here's duval he's got the power
first and third again duvall with the
drive
down the left field line that's a
three-run
homer and the marlins make some noise
here in the third
and the marlins have cut the dodgers
lead in half it's eight to four
they're going to get four back there's a
lot of ball game left partner i'm
telling you so cleveland first guy has
just issued his first walk in the game
now the marlins have two on with one out
in the fifth
and a ground ball that's gonna get down
toward the corner
cooper on his way to second maggie rose
coming in aguilar stops at third and the
marlins now down eight to five
the two hopper past turner gets into the
corner i think that surprised the dodger
defense
two on two out here's brian anderson
sticks with it and strikes him out
ten total tonight for kershaw the
marlins get one and cut it to eight
five he's ten strikeouts for crochet
already a season high
3-2 and it leads to strikeout number 11.
first time he's thrown 100 pitches in a
game since september of 2019
he struck out a season high 11 tonight
2-2 pitch
it's lifted in the air to shallow center
here comes mookie bets he makes a
headlong dive and he makes the grab
a terrific play by mookie betts
magnificent
bases loaded in the seven kevin was nine
years old when dettwither made his big
league debut with the gnats in 2007.
on a two on pitch gavin luck swings and
hits a bullet back to detweiler
[Applause]
gonzalez limits the damage to one keeps
the lead nine
six to the bottom of the eighth marlins
down to their last stow here's garrett
cooper
a one two three and behind an
eight run second inning the dodgers win
their third in a row by a final of 9-6